la droite se dévoile les républicains
ont investi gilles platret le maire de
chalon sur saône pour mener leur liste
aux régionales du printemps prochain
[Applaudissements]
c'est le premier ce soir
le bourguignon conseiller régional
sortant sera secondé dans cette campagne
par le député jurassien jean marie
sermier
un duo qui veut rendre la région plus
attractive et qui pointe l'échec de la
fusion
gilles platret sera le président et moi
je serai le leader pour la franche-comté
parce qu'on a besoin de s'asseoir sur
une région qui travaillent sur deux
identités fortes
la franche comté et la bourgogne nous
avons vraiment le sentiment et nous le
partageons avec jean marie sermier que
la franche comté a été maltraité depuis
cinq ans c'est presque paradoxal mais en
tout cas c'est bien ce qui se passe donc
nous voulons véritablement rétablir un
équilibre entre les deux territoires
ça passera par un certain nombre
d'initiatives fortes ça passera en
particulier par un nouveau nom pour
cette région bourgogne franche comté
personne ne sait ce que c'est
le binôme est adoubé par le président du
parti en personne christian jacob
ravi d'éviter une guerre d'investiture
je viens aujourd'hui pour venir un
accord ils ont pas eu besoin de nous ils
se sont mis d'accord ensemble et sur un
projet de territoire et sur une capacité
à rassembler droite et centre on voit
bien que pour nous la reconstruction
elle se fait par le terrain une union de
la droite et du centre qui inclut des y
met pas la république en marche
si certains républicains se sont alliés
aux maquereaux nistos dernières
municipales gilles platret exclu tout
accord avec la majorité présidentielle
pour ces régionales